chilenas y chilenos
habitantes de nuestra patria
pueblos de chile muy buenos días
me corresponde hoy frente a este
honorable congreso nacional y ante la
ciudadanía todas rendir cuentas acerca
del trabajo que hemos realizado en estos
dos meses y medio de gobierno y exponer
cuáles son los principales ejes de
nuestro proyecto de cambio
quiero hablarles también sobre el
sentido del presente de las urgencias
que estamos atendiendo y del futuro que
debemos construir juntos
de ese futuro más equitativo y
sostenible por el que se han movilizado
millones de ciudadanos y que me han
entregado el mandato de trabajar por el
limpio
un honor y un deber que asumo con mucha
humildad y con mucha mucha
responsabilidad
este proceso de cambio
por cierto no se inicia ni termina con
este gobierno
mejorar la patria en que vivimos es un
desafío de largo aliento que no acepta
promesas fáciles de respuesta simples
requiere de responsabilidad de todos y
todas y también de conciencia histórica
al revisar los discursos inaugurales
ante el congreso nacional de todos
nuestros ex presidentes
desde josé joaquín pérez hasta sebastián
piñera
he podido apreciar la colosal tarea que
significa lograr que nuestro chile
progrese
no es fácil no es obvio no es desde cero
y vale la pena hoy desde el año 2022
pensar las dificultades que enfrentaron
quienes nos antecedieron
para aquilatar de esta forma la magna
obra colectiva que es chile
y comportarnos cada uno a la altura de
nuestras responsabilidades
han habido guerras desastres naturales
crisis políticas y económicas
el dolor del pueblo en sus más diversas
expresiones y conductas
desestabilizadoras que son algunas de
las circunstancias que han enfrentado
quienes dirigieron quienes se dirigieron
a chile desde esta te espera antes que
yo
y sin embargo compatriotas aquí estamos
seguimos siempre seguimos
pero qué es lo que nos hace avanzar
preguntémonos
es acaso la fortaleza de nuestros
líderes
quizás pero es mucho más que eso
serán entonces nuestras centenarias
instituciones
sin duda estas son importantes pero no
son suficientes en sí mismos
podrá ser acaso cada individuo por
separado
cada uno cada una de nosotros es clave
pero por separado no somos historias
lo que nos hace avanzar queridos
compatriotas
es que somos una construcción colectiva
forjada gracias al esfuerzo y al trabajo
conjunto
es cuando nos unimos
respetando nuestras diferencias
cuando mejor nos va como país
como sociedad hemos enfrentado antes
disyuntivas complejas en las que nos
hemos jugado la oportunidad de empezar a
construir una sociedad más inclusiva y
cohesionada pero lamentablemente no
siempre las hemos aprovechado
las esperanzas populares por mayor
justicia en más de una ocasión han sido
opacadas e incluso ahogadas a sangre y
fuego y esta es una historia que también
desde esta tarima oficial tenemos el
deber de contar
es lo que pasó en 1851 y en 1859 cuando
los deseos de las regiones de copiapó
concepción de lograr mayor igualdad de
autonomía fueron acalladas por la fuerza
de las armas
también en 1907 nicky que forra web en
1920 en puntarenas tranquila el 34
cuando obreros campesinos o babuchas
indistintamente fueron asesinados a
mansalva por defender su derecho a una
vida divina
cercano en nuestra memoria
durante la dictadura entre 1973 y 1990
donde la prisión la tortura la muerte y
el exilio se impusieron a quienes
pensaban distinto
hace solo tres años tres años
las muertes de manuel rebolledo alex
núñez romario de los y cristian
valdebenito entre otros
en el marco del estallido social
nos obligaron a una tarea muy dura
de que en nuestro país hay ocasiones en
que protestar se termina pagando con la
vida y eso no lo podemos seguir
permitiendo verdad justicia memoria
reparación y no repetición
son nuestros compromisos como gobiernos
compatriotas
uno de los principales nudos de nuestra
historia republicana ha sido la
concentración del poder en pocas manos y
la persistencia de una sociedad en la
que el lugar de nacimiento determina las
posibilidades del desarrollo de todas
las personas
a pesar del ímpetu de quienes lucharon
por recuperar nuestra democracia a quien
les debemos muchísimo y desde esta te
espera también reconozco su valor su
obra y de los importantes avances
logrados a partir de los años 90 ese
nudo sigue aún vigente
son muchos y muchas quienes quedaron
desplazados de las oportunidades del
crecimiento del país en las últimas
décadas y la política institucional no
se hizo cargo de ese legítimo malestar
que se estaba incubando
así mientras por un lado avanzábamos en
la reducción de la pobreza en mejorar la
conectividad de nuestro territorio el
mayor acceso al consumo la ampliación de
la matrícula en la educación
grandes importantes insoslayables logros
de las últimas décadas por otro lado
también se nos fue consolidando un chile
fragmentado social cultural y
territorialmente
chilenos y chilenos esta fragmentación
es hoy una dolorosa fractura y no
podemos desconocer la dice que
profundizando la quiero ser enfático
después debemos asumir la
responsabilidad de enfrentar las
desigualdades que vive la ciudadanía y
que se expresan en múltiples dimensiones
quiero que construyamos juntos y juntas
un país en donde la educación la salud
la vivienda tu seguridad social no estén
determinadas por cuánta plata tiene tu
familia
son derechos y como tales el estado
tiene el deber de garantizar los
el proyecto
podemos integrar las causas que nos han
llevado a habitar distintos chiles
y permítanme darles un par de ejemplos
que me ha tocado ver directamente
que definen a este chile desigual desde
las regiones y la infancia
cuando estuve hace pocos meses en la
isla de juan fernández visitamos junto
al alcalde el colegio insular isla
robinson crusoe
que funciona en un recinto de emergencia
desde el tsunami que arrasó con parte
importante del poblado en el año 2010
le habían dicho
hace ya varios años que sería una
solución transitoria
pero el año pasado regresó una
generación completa
desde primero a cuarto medio que cursó
sus estudios en esos containers entre
olores inmundos sin las condiciones
dignas que se merecen
no vamos a permitir que esto siga así
lo mismo me tocó ver en montepatria
en donde en el liceo eduardo frei
montalva
se encuentra desde el 2015 en módulos
también de emergencia producto del
terremoto que ese año asoló la zona
lo conversamos con las estudiantes con
los directores del colegio con el
alcalde de la zona
y ha instruido al ministro de educación
para que en ambos casos cuenten con
soluciones definitivas
dentro de nuestro periodo de gobierno a
la mayor brevedad posible
compatriotas
estos son ejemplos
pequeños pero importantes para quienes
los viven
pero son ejemplos de una de una
multiplicidad de injusticias que viven
las mayorías en nuestro país y que
quienes nos están escuchando hoy día
desde sus casas desde sus trabajos
reconocerán seguramente en su vida
cotidiana
la falta de acceso a la salud con listas
de espera eterna
y se os con más infraestructuras
pensiones que no alcanzan para vivir
inseguridad en los barrios
hacinamiento sin vivienda digna son pan
de cada día en nuestra patria
por eso es que el estallido social no
fue un evento aislado fue una explosión
de múltiples malestar y descontento que
fueron ignorados o minimizados por
décadas sin por ello
porque esto no es blanco y negro sin por
ello desconocer los avances de los
últimos años
fueron millones los que se reconocieron
en problemas comunes y se organizaron
para que las cosas sean distintos
y todos juntos decidimos encauzar ese
malestar por una vía institucional
mediante un plebiscito en donde el 80
por ciento de los votantes manifestó que
quería una nueva constitución para china
hoy
tenemos
hoy honorable congreso tenemos la
tremenda oportunidad de recomponer las
confianza entre el pueblo y sus
instituciones de hacernos cargo de estas
urgencias a ellos estamos abocados como
gobiernos en definitiva de cambiar para
preservar lo más valioso de nosotros ser
parte de un mismo camino
de eso entiendo se trata el proceso
constituyente hoy hemos
a pesar de enfrentar una pandemia con un
clima difícil de polarización política y
crisis institucional
en el marco de un amplio proceso de
debate y deliberación democrática se ha
logrado avanzar en la redacción de un
borrador de nueva constitución quiero
decir que no es poco
había otro pieza han habido errores y
también muchos aprendizajes en el camino
pero si hoy los podemos evaluar y esto
es quizás lo más importante de nuestra
experiencia recientes y hoy lo podemos
evaluar es justamente porque en el
momento más crítico de nuestra historia
reciente
optamos por resolver nuestras
diferencias con más democracia y no con
menos
a este honorable congreso
a que no pasemos de la triste frase
no lo vimos venir
aquí no ha pasado nada
el 4 de septiembre el próximo nos vamos
a enfrentar a una decisión trascendental
aprobar o rechazar la propuesta de una
nueva constitución
quiero decir con mucha claridad que
ambas opciones son legítimas y que el
gobierno tiene el deber de garantizar
que la ciudadanía se manifieste
libremente en las urnas de manera
informada
compatriotas
quisiera que fuéramos recordado como un
gobierno que dio pasos claros y
decididos en la construcción de una
sociedad sin privilegios ni abusos esa
es la tarea que hemos asumido sentar las
bases del cine que alineamos construir
para las niñas y los niños de hoy para
las futuras generaciones sin descuidar
las urgencias del presente
y eso tenemos que hacerlo reconociendo
también el valor de la opinión de que
empieza a distinto
reconociendo como decía antes que no
partimos de cero
escuchando con ánimo de aprender con
menos soberbia con más humildad
entre estas urgencias del presente
[Música]
sin duda la pandemia del coi 19 que
luego de más de 2 años nos sigue
golpeando concierto con cerca de 7 mil
casos promedio diario está tremendamente
presente las consecuencias de esta
pandemia en todas sus dimensiones
especialmente en lo humano nos
acompañarán por mucho tiempo
debemos salir adelante pero por favor
sin olvidar a quienes han partido
son más de 57 mil personas
57 mil personas que nuestra patria han
fallecido y el dolor que se ha causado
es inmenso
hay un proyecto en el congreso para
recordarlo desde el día del deceso de la
primera persona fallecida por kobe 19
que por cierto como gobierno vamos a
respaldar pero desde este espacio
institucional quiero abrazar a cada
familia que ha perdido un ser querido y
decirles que no van a estar solos
quiero reconocer también y valorar a
todas las trabajadores y trabajadores de
la salud que han cumplido un rol
fundamental y nos han enseñado lo que
significan
el compromiso con la vida
reconozco también
[Aplausos]
la labor
dedicación y los aprendizajes de las
autoridades del ministerio de salud del
gobierno de mi predecesor sebastián
piñera
para nadie era
fácil ni obvio como había que abordarlo
y si en algún momento fuimos injustos de
las críticas quiero reconocer que lo
hicimos de buena fe
y que entendemos las dificultades que es
afrontar algo tan complejo como una
pandemia desconocida para el mundo
no ha sido fácil tampoco para las
pequeñas de miles de empresas y medianas
pequeñas que están dedicadas a los
servicios del turismo y muchas otras
actividades que se vieron afectadas y
que lograron salir adelante porque
ustedes lo saben lo han visto en sus
distritos detrás de cada negocio hay una
cadena de esfuerzo colectivo de
emprendedores trabajadores proveedores y
familias que debemos proteger
los vamos a apoyar y daré cuenta en el
discurso como reconozco también el
sacrificio de miles de profesores y
profesoras que lograron sacar adelante
la tarea de educar en medio de tan
difíciles
a los millones de estudiantes
que se han reintegrado la presencialidad
sepan que cuentan con este presidente y
con todo nuestro gobierno
y quiero que sepan que pondremos
especial énfasis en quien es producto de
la pandemia desertaron de la educación
los queremos recuperar y vamos a agotar
todos los esfuerzos para lograrlo
es la humanidad completa a la que está
viviendo tiempos difíciles
enfrentamos los desafíos globales y
nuestro país sabemos no está exento a
las consecuencias que generan los
conflictos internacionales
en 1916 el presidente sanz fuente se
lamentaba por la gran guerra en europa y
en particular por sus efectos sobre el
precio del salitre chileno y en 1942
juan antonio ríos desde esta misma
testera hacia lo propio aunque desde
santiago respecto a la segunda guerra
mundial hoy asistimos con estupor a la
ilegítima invasión de rusia ucrania
desde el sur del mundo denunciamos las
brutales consecuencias sociales y de
derechos humanos que ha generado esta
guerra de agresión y por eso durante las
últimas semanas he tenido conversaciones
con líderes mundiales y regionales tales
como emanuel macrón justin crudo alberto
fernández antonio guterres jacinta arden
o boris johnson para evaluar en conjunto
las consecuencias de este conflicto y
promover
multilateralmente la paz chile es un
actor en el mundo y nuestra opinión como
país no la mía personal la del estado de
chile es respetada y valorada y he
podido sentir eso en estas y muchas
otras conversaciones
quiero que el mundo sepa que chile es
profundamente latinoamericano y desde
américa latina es desde donde
levantaremos nuestra voz en defensa de
los derechos humanos y la cooperación
entre los pueblos sin subordinarlos
jamás ante ninguna potencia extranjera
compatriotas la situación global de la
guerra y la pandemia tiene efectos
negativos en la cadena de suministros y
en el alza de precios de los
combustibles que son elementos que
sabemos contribuyen decisivamente a la
inflación y el alza del costo de la vida
perjudica especialmente a quienes menos
tienen y viven exclusivamente de su
trabajo
para enfrentarla debemos ser
responsables
por ello es que junto con fortalecer la
resiliencia de la economía y de las
finanzas que nos permite responder a
emergencias sin que yo de rieles
recursos y atención en el camino de
transformaciones de largo plazo en el
que estamos empeñados debemos enfrentar
la tentación de las soluciones
supuestamente fáciles pero que generan a
la larga más problemas
la historia nos enseña
que las transformaciones profundas
requieren de convicción y persistencia y
que no existen atajos
en los últimos años
todos hemos estado sentados en algún
momento a seguir este camino cediendo a
la presión de las redes sociales
o a la arrogancia de creerse a vernos
los todos
reunir evidencias decir la verdad
trabajar duro y construir consensos sin
embargo es quizás más difícil pero es la
única forma de responder
responsable y oportunamente a las
aspiraciones de nuestro pueblo y estar a
la altura de este momento histórico
pero que no se vaya a confundir esta
responsabilidad
con la inacción
es en esta convicción que hemos
desplegado junto con nuestro gobierno
nuestros ministros y nuestros equipos de
trabajo
tanto desde la moneda como también en
regiones el plan chile apoyo que
moviliza más de 3 mil 700 millones de
dólares y creará medio millón de empleos
de los que al menos la mitad serán
femeninos
él
en los próximos 60 días
estarán operando todas las líneas de
este plan incluyendo inversiones en
obras locales con servicios públicos
municipios y gobiernos regionales
además hemos congelado las tarifas del
transporte público regulado por todo
este año y como los inviernos hicieran
ver parlamentarios de distintas regiones
estamos estudiando las alternativas para
los casos del transporte público no
regulado
inyectamos fondos para la estadidad para
estabilizar el precio de la parafina
disminuyendo su precio directamente en
más de 300 pesos por litro lo que
beneficia a más de un millón de hogares
y para evitar
mejor les pido que lo noten porque
muchas veces estos esfuerzos no se ven
se diluyen en medio de las noticias en
medio de las dificultades pero para
evitar un incremento que habría sido de
más de 400 pesos
por litro de bencina hemos dotado de
cerca de tres mil millones de dólares al
fondo del mecanismo de estabilización de
precios de los combustibles
tres mil millones de dólares
hay países que no tienen la oportunidad
de hacer
y desde este lugar
me complace y también asumo la tremenda
responsabilidad que significa destinar
tantos recursos
a cuestiones que afectan tanto la vida
de la gente que sabemos que les
preocupan
somos conscientes de cuánto aumentado el
valor del arroz el pan el aceite las
verduras
y el impacto que esto tiene en el
bolsillo de las chilenas y los chilenos
le digo permanentemente a mi gobierno
que tenemos que estar en terreno que
tenemos que ir a la feria que tenemos
que estar viendo lo que el pueblo ve
porque cuando la política se desconecta
de esa realidad
cuando no hay conciencia de cuánto
cuesta el pan de cuánto cuesta la vida
diaria es cuando se produce este quiebre
entre instituciones y ciudadanía
por eso a partir de este mandato de
estar en terreno es que hemos elaborado
también un aporte adicional para cubrir
el alza de la canasta básica que quiero
destacar que es un mecanismo que
beneficia a más de 1.600.000 familias
que reciben la asignación o subsidio
familiar no podemos permitir no podemos
permitir que por esta crisis el cuidado
de niños personas mayores y personas con
discapacidad
recaiga exclusivamente en los hombros de
millones de mujeres y es por esto que
siguiendo nuestro programa de gobierno
que a su vez se nutre de las reflexiones
y aprendizajes del movimiento feminista
es que impulsaremos la creación de un
sistema nacional de cuidado
y ahora sabemos avanzaremos en
corresponsabilidad porque las mujeres
han demostrado en chile y en el mundo
que no existen cargos prestados para
ella
y lo mismo aunque en otros sentidos
corre para los hombres que aún rechazan
o se resisten a realizar labores de
cuidado por ser supuestamente tareas
femeninos nomás
recordando el movimiento feminista que
tanto ha cambiado nuestro país
democracia en el país y en la casa
queridos compatriotas tengo la
convicción profunda de que es imposible
volver a encontrarnos para juntos y
juntas sanar las heridas que nos dividen
y fracturan para darle estabilidad al
camino de los grandes cambios debemos
hacerlo con la participación de todo
nuestro pueblo y quiero ser enfático sin
exclusiones en esto la participación
conjunta de trabajadores y empresarios
es fundamental su presencia hoy día en
nuestra cuenta pública es una señal de
voluntad por caminar juntos hacia un
chile mejor ya ustedes les digo que mi
gobierno está trabajando para construir
las condiciones de estabilidad necesaria
para que chile crezca y se desarrolle y
es justamente a través del diálogo con
ustedes que podremos construir
transformaciones sociales que sean
estables
un ejemplo claro concreto de esto son
los procesos participativos que están
llevando a cabo en el marco de la
reforma de pensiones y la reforma
tributaria
quiero que esta manera de hacer las
cosas las repliquemos en muchos más
ámbitos por ejemplo en lo que hemos
logrado recientemente sobre el salario
mínimo en donde destacó el acuerdo
alcanzado con la cut y con la central
unitaria de trabajadores que involucra
la mayor alza en los últimos 23 años
quiero agregar que la implementación del
nuevo salario mínimo viene de la mano
con el acuerdo al que llegamos con todas
las organizaciones de pymes muchas de
ellas aquí presentes para que nadie se
quede atrás
a todas y todos quienes participaron de
estos esfuerzos liderados por nuestra
ministra del trabajo nuestro ministro de
economía nuestro ministro de hacienda
las organizaciones de pymes a las
organizaciones de grandes empresarios
que también fueron parte del debate
y por cierto a este congreso nacional
que transmito con celeridad este
proyecto les agradezco profundamente
son ustedes que están aquí presentes un
ejemplo de que cuando nos unimos podemos
hacer las cosas bien más allá de las
legítimas diferencias es así como
queremos avanzar
tienen dos chilenas
las cosas no han sido fáciles para
nuestro país pero a la vez soy optimista
tengo esperados porque tenemos por
delante un futuro esplendor y depende de
todas y todos hacerlo en conjunto
realidad
quiero ser convocante que esta esperanza
y la confianza en el porvenir compartido
se impongan por sobre el derrotismo y la
sospecha
en este momento histórico
nos enfrentamos a la gran tarea de
consolidar e institucionalizar
los cambios que la ciudadanía reclama y
hacerlo en paz con estabilidad entre
todos y todas sin que nadie sin que
nadie se queda afuera
para abordar los desafíos y
transformaciones que llevaremos a cabo
siguiendo este espíritu es que
agrupar en esta cuenta pública en 5x
derechos sociales mejor democracia
justicia y seguridad crecimiento
inclusivo y medioambiente
partiendo por derechos sociales
llegamos a gobernar con el mandato claro
de concretar una agenda de camino
y es nuestro deber dar respuesta a las
incertidumbres a las que se enfrentan
millones de chilenos y chilenas que
viven todos los días en un país que
carece todavía de una base sólida de
derechos sociales el gasto privado en
salud en educación
en complemento de las pensiones
demasiado alto en chile
el rascarse con las propias uñas es
demasiado común
llevamos décadas debatiendo sobre un
cambio en el sistema de fp y llegó el
momento de construir un verdadero
sistema de seguridad social en donde
nuestras legítimas ideologías
no entrante la necesidad de los chilenos
y chilenas de tener una pensión digna
es por ello
y en agosto de este año adelantando los
plazos que habíamos comprometido al
comienzo del gobierno enviaremos un
proyecto de ley que reforma
estructuralmente el sistema previsional
aprendiendo por cierto de los debates
que hemos tenido antes y que va a ser
resultado de un proceso de diálogo
social amplio con participación de
trabajadoras empleadores expertos
académicos y por cierto
con la importante participación de este
congreso nacional para despejar
cualquier fantasma quiero decir muy
claramente que vamos a respetar cada
peso de los ahorros previsionales
acumulados las cuentas individuales
y la posibilidad de verlo
para su juicio
además me comprometo a que con esta
reforma en un régimen cada habitante de
nuestra patria de 65 años o más tendrá
derecho de una pensión básica
garantizada por el estado de al menos
250 mil pesos
reconozco el avance que se dio al
finalizar el gobierno anterior con la
pgv es la base sobre la cual vamos a
construir y cumplir este compromiso
en materia de salud
en el camino de las grandes reformas
sabemos que no lo estamos empezando bien
reconociendo los avances sustantivos que
se realizaron durante los gobiernos del
ex presidente lagos y la ex presidenta
michelle bachelet
sabemos que el tiempo para una reforma
integral al sistema de salud ha llegado
para esto presentaremos un proyecto de
ley que creará un fondo universal de
salud con el objetivo de generar mayor
equidad en el acceso a servicios mejorar
la atención
aumentar la solidaridad el
financiamiento del sistema y reducir el
gasto de los hogares
además disminuiremos el topado el
sistema público de salud para las
personas de los tramos 6 desde zonas
beneficiando más de 6 millones de
personas
y una convicción que yo imagino que
todos ustedes también la adquieren
cuando recorren sus distritos y es que
la salud no puede seguir siendo un
negocio no se puede seguir discriminando
entre ricos y pobres no puede haber
atención en función de cuánta plata
puede pagar la salud es un derecho y así
lo vamos a garantizar
[Música]
en el estudio de los discursos de
presidentes anteriores
revisaba
algunos compromisos que se hicieron a
esta materia todos los presidentes se
referían a este tema pero me sorprendió
como
[Música]
en los últimos años desgraciadamente ya
que no estoy atribuyendo una
responsabilidad específica es
responsabilidad de todos hoy día y de
nuestro gobierno en particular el día de
hoy hemos retrocedido mucho en
particular en materia de lista de espera
la pandemia sin lugar a dudas fue
determinante en esto y las personas del
país que están en espera de resolver
más de 330 mil cirugías deben esperar un
promedio de 600 dos días de espera
seiscientos dos días de espera en el
caso de las cirugías electivas y estas
cifras compatriotas no son tolerables
por eso este año
encomendado a nuestra ministra de salud
la elaboración e implementación no
elaboración implementación de un plan de
resolución de listas de espera
quirúrgica que contempla la puesta en
marcha de tres centros regionales de
resolución para cirugía mayor
ambulatoria en coquimbo valparaíso y
araucanía llegando a siete centros
en el 2023
tenido nuestro mandato
nos preocuparemos de que toda cirugía
oncológica sea resuelta en menos de 90
días y toda cirugía de mayor riesgo sea
resuelta antes de seis meses
además sabemos
sabemos que la salud mental no puede
esperar y va a ser una prioridad de
nuestro gobierno
vamos a comenzar por construir 12
centros de salud mental comunitaria
mediante una inversión de 36 mil
millones de pesos comenzando este año en
san antonio en el puerto de san antonio
y el 2023 seguiremos con antofagasta
iquique
además
vamos a fortalecer el programa de apoyo
a la salud mental infantil duplicando
sus comunas y ampliando la cobertura a
los tres y cuatro años
estamos comprometidos también con el
derecho a los cuidados paliativos y la
muerte digna y es por esto que hoy
ingresaremos la urgencia a la
tramitación del proyecto de ley que
establece el derecho a la eutanasia en
chile- mediante un proceso
el proceso de consentimiento expreso y
[Música]
respetando y respetando a quienes
estarán
compatriotas sabemos que la pandemia no
ha terminado
y la vacunación así como las medidas
sanitarias siguen siendo prioritarias
para enfrentar el 19 y es deber de
nuestro gobierno asegurar la
disponibilidad y provisión de vacunas
que
también se hizo durante el gobierno
recién pasado
las buenas políticas públicas tenemos
que continuar las como políticas de
estado
en materia de vivienda y ciudad sabemos
y de seguro ustedes lo ven
permanentemente en sus territorios que
estamos ante una emergencia habitacional
quizás nunca antes vista en chile
para enfrentarla vamos a comenzar
con la construcción de 65.000 viviendas
dignas para llegar a nuestra meta de 260
mil viviendas entregadas a fines de
gobierno
para esto
me entristece decirte que no nos
merecemos tantos aplausos porque nos
gustaría mucho más el déficit de
vivienda es mucho más grande pero
también no podemos prometer cosas que no
vamos a poder cumplir el déficit de
vivienda en chile- compatriotas es de
650 mil viviendas hoy día decía que esto
quizás no se había visto antes quizás en
la década de los días de los 20 a
propósito de la migración campo-ciudad
vivimos algo parecido pero tenemos que
avanzar más rápido
por eso le pidió a nuestro ministro de
vivienda y urbanismo que ponga todo el
corazón que sé que tiene grande en esta
tarea para eso también ampliaremos el
banco de suelo de destinando terrenos
fiscales hacia fines habitacionales y
recuperando terrenos fiscales yermos en
desuso también vamos a aumentar la
oferta de viviendas en arriendo un
precio justo
honorables congresistas
hoy son más de 81 mil familias las que
viven en campamentos nuestro país en
condiciones que son inseguras e
inciertas todos los hemos recorrido
he estado
en las culatas en valdivia en alto
hospicio
en su momento en puño en alto en punta
arena
en tomas el hampa
en las caletas de tarapacá
y esta cifra sólo ha ido en aumento
desde el año 2014
no podemos permitir
y episodios como el incendio ocurrido el
20 de mayo de este año en alto hospicio
en el que murieron nueve personas se
repitan
estas muertes los duelen profundamente y
al mismo tiempo nos tienen que movilizar
por eso vamos a desarrollar la política
construyendo barrios que nos permitan a
ella ustedes lo están viendo desde ser
parte de lo que ha sido este discurso de
cuenta pública como lo llaman en chile
en esto pues las cuentas que ha sido su
gobierno y hacia dónde va el gobierno
del presidente chileno gabriel moris y
quiero conectar entonces con nuestra
enviada especial precisamente a
valparaíso donde se encuentra en este
momento el presidente de chile en el
congreso dando este discurso de cuenta
pública patricia hagamos entonces un
resumen de lo que ha sido esta primera
parte de el discurso que ha pronunciado
gabriel boric
bueno un discurso dentro de las claves
de lo esperado con muchas referencias
históricas también reconocimiento a los
gobiernos pasados en los que ha habido
alguna recopilación de las medidas que
ya se habían anunciado como por ejemplo
esa de la creación de medio millón de
empleos de 3700 millones de dólares en
programas especiales en chile pero
también nuevos anuncios como puede ser
el hecho de que se enviara al congreso
una ley para por ejemplo la eutanasia se
incrementarán el monto de las pensiones
y todas las personas en chile todos los
adultos tendrán una pensión básica de
250 mil pesos muy por encima de la
actual que se encuentra en torno a las
140 y 165 mil 180 mil pesos y también
reformas al sistema de salud se creará
un fondo universal de salud también es
una de las demandas claves que había
solicitado la ciudadanía desde hace
mucho tiempo vemos entonces algunas
medidas concretas que van en la línea de
las demandas sociales de la revuelta
y de la ciudadanía en general un
discurso en el que también ha habido
muchas referencias al estallido al
proceso constitucional también al hecho
de que en chile- protestar se puede
acabar pagando en algunos casos con la
muerte ha mencionado algunas de las
personas fallecidas durante el estallido
social y también ha dicho que llevarán a
cabo programas de reparación y no
repetición de las violaciones de los
derechos humanos
eso es más o menos algunos de los
aspectos más destacados de este gabriel
boric que ha señalado también como lo
hacía su antecesor el presidente
sebastián piñera que chile unido
trabajando unidos respetando las
diferencias saca su inversión en su
mejor versión eso sonaba mucho a la
administración de piñera y también que
ha hecho una ha señalado en varias
ocasiones que no partimos de cero ha
hecho reconocimientos a gobiernos
anteriores como el gobierno de michelle
bachelet o de ricardo lagos- de
anteriores gobiernos lo que también
marca un tono distinto a la el boliche
el diputado que fue muy crítico en su
momento con algunos de estos gobiernos
así es patricia también el presidente
boris y dijo quiero enfocar entonces
parte de lo que le queda de su discurso
en cinco ejes él decía derecho social
democracia seguridad también el derecho
inclusivo y medioambiente quiero
patricia pues también incluir a nuestra
conversación a nuestros analistas que
estamos precisamente conversando con
ellos o previo a este discurso de boris
y guillermo holzmann analista político
internacionalista y profesor
universitario y michel huffman miembro
de la red de politólogos guillermo
quiero empezar con usted pues para ver
las primeras impresiones de lo que ha
sido esta primera parte del discurso del
presidente de chile gabriel boric porque
recordemos que todavía continúa el
discurso como ya ha aparecido hasta
ahora predecible digamos el parecido
conciso lo que ha dicho el presidente
boris yo creo que está sorprendiendo en
primer lugar un discurso mucho más largo
lo que se estaba esperando con mucho más
detalle
encima introducción como bien decía la
creencia histórica a una introducción de
contexto respecto en qué momento
estábamos e incluso sorprendiendo
respecto al estudio de discursos
presidenciales anteriores para poder
tener efectivamente un adecuado foco yo
diría que la primera reacción que suma a
este discurso es que es un discurso que
busca empatía es empático empático y con
todos los sectores y juniors que es es
una imagen amable que presente parece
que está está mostrando en una en una
búsqueda de recuperar la épica del
govern el relato del jugador de espectar
diego la cual fue electo no pasa
desapercibido de la todas las encuestas
de ica subió nunca vamos ha ido
perdiendo popularidad la desaprobación
ha ido aumentando y creo que está
justamente haciendo el esfuerzo para el
colocar
en lo que sería la agenda futura y esa
agenda futura que el presidente está
instalando se basa en la empatía en la
emoción que fue lo que justamente le
permitió llegar a la segunda vuelta con
un tono triunfador que fue claramente
sin indiscutible entonces creo que hay
una primera cosa y a su vez también con
muchos pocos en en poder ayudar a las
familias tienen la particularmente
aquellas que tienen menos recursos o
imposibilidad de por lograrlo para poder
sobrellevar todo todo lo que es la
inflación en el momento económico que
mantiene michele quiero saber entonces
ahora su opinión de lo que ha sido de
esta primera parte de lo que hemos
podido escuchar del discurso del
presidente acabe el boliche ante el
congreso de la república
sí yo creo que es lo que hemos podido
escuchar hasta ahora vemos ya
definitivamente una bajada de la
propuesta programática del presidente de
boliche al momento de hacer su campaña y
asumir el gobierno ya en proyectos
específicos para ir apuntando en esta
primera parte es cierto a los sociales
les ha definido cinco ejes en este
discurso para sus anuncios y el primero
que alcanzamos a escuchar es el social y
da cuenta de una serie de proyectos de
ley y en el fondo
e iniciativas públicas que van a abordar
los distintos problemas que en estos
momentos
se manifiestan o que se han identificado
como el problema en cuanto a las bajas
pensiones se promete una reforma de que
va a mejorar las pensiones incluso el
asuma un compromiso personal de que el
término de su mandato en las pensiones
alcancen unos doscientos cincuenta mil
pesos como mínimo también se establece
un
proyecto para abordar los problemas en
cuanto a atenciones de salud o
específicamente la larga lista de espera
que hay de personas que están esperando
una cirugía que son aproximadamente 330
miles y desarrolla entonces la idea de
la generación de centros de salud a
nivel regional que van a lograr de
cierta forma descomprimir está sobre
esta sobre sobre
demanda que hay en el sistema y que no
está haciendo respondía hasta ahora
también creo que mantiene su línea en
la relevancia que le ha dado hasta ahora
como presidente y también que le dio en
su campaña a la salud mental en este
sentido lo aborda con el desarrollo del
centro de salud a nivel regional y
quisiera destacar al mismo tiempo que
mantiene su sello en cuanto a el rol de
la mujer no y también este foco
feminista de la política pública en el
sentido de que al momento de plantear
generar 500.000 empleos para abordar la
crisis de desempleo en el fondo para de
cierta forma lograr avanzar en la
empleabilidad por lo que se había
retrocedido en la pandemia que el 50 por
ciento de estos empleos se han destinado
a mujeres que sólo fueron uno de los
segmentos más perjudicados en este
sentido ya que muchas mujeres tuvieron
que decidir trabajar o cuidar y en ese
mismo sentido también es ratificado
nuevamente propone el anuncio de la
creación de un sistema de cuidado en el
fondo para compensar a las mujeres que
se ven
aquí ven una baja en sus ingresos que de
cierta forma serán limitadas en su en su
capacidad de destinar horas al trabajo
porque tienen que asumir los roles de
cuidados domésticos y hace un llamado
también a los hombres no va a hacerse
cargo de participar en este sentido y
allí quizás me faltó pero podría ser que
fuera incluido en otro aspecto más
adelante un anuncio respecto de un
posnatal masculino por seguro guillermo
también pues desglosemos un poco el
anuncio de boliche respecto a la reforma
pensional y también habló de la reforma
integral al sistema de salud chileno que
es tan necesario son digamos estas dos
reformas y también qué tan viables son
en el sil actual sin ello le ha colocado
viviría una hoja de ruta entre menos
derechos sociales particularmente lo que
es pensiones y salud que es a cuatro
años reconociendo que ya los avances que
se habían realizado anteriormente en
todos esos derechos sociales lo que
llama la atención es el énfasis que está
colocando el presidente de los diálogos
ciudadanos en la participación ciudadana
y en el hecho de que efectivamente haya
una y un proceso de consulta permanente
para poder llegar al congreso y pedir
que se apruebe justamente en los
proyectos de ley asociado todo eso por
lo pronto es lo que se respira pensiones
él está en la idea de por qué es una
pensión básica garantizada al final de
su periodo que estaría como sigue
aproximadamente en 350 dólares
aproximadamente los 250 mil pesos que
nación a mikel y eso es quizás e
interesante pero eso hay que financiarlo
el financiamiento tiene que ver con la
reforma estructural del sistema de
pensiones donde aseguró y dejó muy claro
de que el ahorro individual que cada
quien no tiene no va a ser tocado ni va
a ser apropiado ni va a tener ninguna
ninguna modificación pero también dejó
entrever de que el próximo sistema va a
tener una base solidaria muy potente se
va a mantener algo de este ahorro
individual para las pensiones pero se va
a garantizar que todos tengan una
pensión que sea efectivamente
efectivamente digna por lo tanto va a
haber cambios sistema de hábito respondo
canción actualmente existente
probablemente modificaciones u otras
formaciones relevantes pero se va a
mantener un proceso de capitalización
individual y lo propio con lo que una
reforma integral del sistema de salud
donde efectivamente han da cuenta de la
necesidad que es pueda avanzar no
solamente en la lista de espera sino que
generando ya esos centros que puedan que
vamos a hacer de de núcleos para poder
superar ahorita de espera en varias
regiones del país va a empezar con dos
se va a ampliar a siete de esta forma
que las y llegar a un nivel donde la
cirugía oncológica no tienen sepan
resolver en menos de 90 días y la
cirugía mayores también rápidamente y
eso es más tantos en ese minuto lo que
la cifra que era el presidente de que
hay cirugía que tienen una lista de
espera un tiempo de espera superior a
600 días claramente lo impacta y en ese
sentido también lo otro es que está la
afecta a la idea de salud mental y muy
interesante es no solamente colocar los
centros que ha comprometido en términos
de preocuparse de ellos sino también ese
foco en la salud mental en los niños de
34 años a niños o probablemente va a ser
un elemento que va a tener un impacto
muy positivo por diversas razones que el
propio presidente ha dicho algunas de
ellas pero que a nivel de cohesión
social si luego era duda base de bases
importantes y lo propio también en lo
que se refiere a viviendas hay en el
hecho de pueda avanzar de servicios de
viviendas
con los planes en concreto en términos
de uso términos fiscales el terminar los
campamentos pero siendo muy claro y
transparente y ahí está la empático
también en términos de decir que el
déficit de viviendas en cantidades de
600 mil militantes
nosotros no podemos superar todo eso
pero sí podemos hacer algo que aquí en
lo que está ofreciendo ahora su discurso
así es michel también por hecha del
proceso constituyente de la importancia
del movimiento feminista dentro de chile
y hablo del plebiscito que va a ser el
próximo 4 de septiembre donde los
chilenos van a aprobar digamos este
texto que se está cocinando de este
cambio esta modificación a la
constitución chilena que tan importante
sería este este plebiscito
la política para para la política
chilena y también para la
institucionalidad y que se espera no de
este plebiscito como irían las cosas los
chilenos realmente estarían dispuestos a
aceptar este plebiscito y realmente
modificar la constitución chilena
si tienes
micrófonos
no quería decir que primero que todo
quisiera destacar el hecho que el
presidente señaló que tanto da la opción
a prueba como la opción rechazo son
opciones válidas para la
manifestación de preferencias de los
ciudadanos al momento del plebiscito del
4 de septiembre pero sin embargo en su
introducción que comencé a la
corresponsal fue una con una instrucción
bastante larga pero también con carácter
de bastante histórico en el fondo de
darle un contexto a esta cuenta pública
en el marco de la trayectoria histórica
del país señaló que este es
efectivamente un proceso muy relevante
para el país en un momento en que los
chilenos y chilenas van a poder elegir
si mantiene la constitución vigente que
la constitución que tuvo origen en 1980
en el régimen de pinochet con las
reformas posteriores
o aprueban el proyecto de constitución
que es que se presente al término del
trabajo de la convención constitucional
que va a suceder es muy difícil decirlo
a él ahora por supuesto hay una serie de
encuentros que manifiestan una
preferencia en uno o en otro sentido
pero de que estamos frente a un proceso
histórico en este sentido es evidente
que sí por qué porque en el fondo la
constitución de ciertas formas va a dar
el marco cierto a la institucionalidad y
también va a suponer supuestamente va a
expresar todas las demandas que dieron
origen a este proceso que fueron las que
las que se manifestaron en el estado
social entonces debiera haber cierta
sincronía cierto entonces en este
proyecto con un foco social muy fuerte
del presidente boris y esta nueva
constitución de llegarse a aprobar
guillermo ay hablemos entonces también
de este plebiscito que va a ver el
próximo 4 de septiembre y esta nueva
constitución que estaría por aprobación
o no por parte de los chilenos cuál es
su opinión al respecto que qué piensa
sobre todo este proceso constituyente
que hoy en día está en curso en chile
producto del estallido social del año
2019 al que hizo también referencia el
presidente boris
exactamente un estudio social que en su
minuto finalmente abre este proceso
constitucional con la marcha masiva de
25 de octubre aquí es donde
efectivamente se manifiesta todo ese
proceso luego apoyado como indicó
presidente un 80% toda la ciudadanía que
en el principio entrega opta por este
proceso en consecuencia este proceso
constitucional es la respuesta a una
crisis política institucional este
presentó se cierra el 4 de septiembre
con las dos opciones al que ya conocemos
el apruebo rechazo a la constitución y
en esa perspectiva que julian que es un
proceso que tiene de dulce y de grasa o
sea necesita hay cosas que se han sido
muy positiva y cosas que sean
transparentados han visibilizado dentro
de la discusión y las necesidades del
país y la expectativa que hay lo segundo
también que es importante y que
efectivamente la ciudadanía en forma
mayoritaria independiente de su visión
política tiene un deseo de
transformación y que esas las
formaciones se hagan en forma
institucional
es evidente de que terminado el 4
septiembre conocidos el resultado vamos
a tener que mirar cómo se hace la
campaña y hoy el grana gran lluvia
fantasma o la gran preocupación es que
esa esta campaña sea de polarización sin
embargo uno mira los estudios de opinión
y nos encontramos con que nos
encontramos con que la gente está cada
vez más alejada de la política y ahí yo
rescato lo que el presente está
señalando ante eliminó de reencantar con
la política hasta la encantarse con la
política pero claramente a mayor
distanciamiento a la gente la política
probablemente el apoyo del rechazo
respecto con la nueva constitución no va
a pasar tanto por el contenido sino por
las percepciones y por y probablemente
por una visión mucho más sellada o
incluso ideológica que bastan culminada
por los es por los extremos sobre
minorías como se interesa a la cual
hemos dicho ha hecho referencia es
curioso pero el cuarto septiembre de ahí
que cuando septiembre vamos a tener yo
lo siguiente etapa de ahora cuando
termine la cuenta pública y la confianza
y en el pacto que tenga esta cuenta
pública presente política el 29 de junio
que sea que se va a terminar todas las
comisiones y vamos del borrador final
del 29 de junio hasta el 2 de septiembre
probablemente un par de días antes que
va a ser la campaña por el aprueba de
rechazo y es ahí donde está el mayor en
riesgo de que esto se polariza y que
finalmente todo este proceso
institucional no cumpla con el objetivo
que se había pensado para el cual fue
convocado independiente y la opción
aprueba
también os voy a preguntar ahora
guillermo michelle rápidamente ya para
finalizar me llamó la atención también
este discurso que a diferencia después
de llegarse un poco de estas políticas
tradicionales que fue finalmente también
eso que de cierto modo lo llevó a la
presidencia al presidente gabriel boric
en ese sentido agradeció muchísimo al
gobierno del presidente sebastián piñera
como por todo el apoyo por todas las
políticas que había hecho porque lo
porque lo ha hecho de esta de esta
manera michelle en su opinión
sí bueno lo que hizo el presidente en
este discurso en específico fue
reconocer el manejo de la pandemia por
parte del gobierno del presidente piñera
y eso es algo innegable en chile tenemos
tasas de vacunación muy alta y vamos en
este momento en el despliegue de una
campaña por una cuarta dosis de las
vacunas contra el cob y entonces fue yo
creo que fundar un reconocimiento justo
y también asumió que desde otra posición
y también bien como lo decía la
corresponsal también como diputado fue
muy crítico del manejo de parte del
gobierno anterior estos en ese sentido
creo que lo que hizo fue una concesión a
reconocer por una parte el rol de los
funcionarios de salud y por otra parte
el rol de la autoridad en ese momento
del gobierno en la conducción de la
medida sanitaria de la campaña de
vacunación durante la pandemia del coi
guillermo su opinión
y yo dije presidente yo lo que hablan lo
que ha planteado es una es un ambicioso
plan de trabajo un ambicioso plan no un
hoja de ruta
y digo ambicioso porque primero no tiene
mayoría en el congreso en consecuencia
tiene que negociar y negociar con un
congreso que está además fragmentado no
es tarea fácil y este elemento creo que
va a ser fundamental hoy día con el
discurso empático cercano con todas las
propuestas e incluso en forma muy
transparente de que lo que se puede o no
se puede hacer en cuatro años en
definitiva también que termina siendo un
elemento que puede jugar en contra puede
ser un bumerán en términos de que si no
logra los acuerdos políticos
definitivamente su gobierno se puede
encontrar atrapado claro si no se logra
una buena contribución también sería lo
mismo pues guillermo gracias por su
análisis también michelle gracias por su
análisis por estar los dos en este
especial de noticias de france de tipo
está analizando un poco lo que ha sido
esta primera parte del discurso de
cuenta pública del presidente de chile
gabriel esports en estos dos meses y
medio que lleva del gobierno y también
esbozando un poco lo que sería su
proyecto final para finalizar su mandato
de aquí a cuatro años que le quedan
porque recordemos que está apenas
empezando este ejecutivo de gabriel
boric guillermo holzmann analista
político internacional y también el
profesor universitario ugel huffman
miembro de la red de politólogos ha sido
realmente un gusto y placer haber
compartido este espacio con ustedes
guillermo y michel no gracias vuelven
muy bien igual guillermo y muchas
gracias a ustedes por la invitación
hasta luego nos vemos en una próxima
oportunidad